where do we want to go next let's try
maybe the five-10 area code caller from
five-10 go ahead
uh hello your honor hey hey David thanks
for receiving my call oh my pleasure I
just I just had a question what the tax
cut that they did where what was being
paid with that money you know and where
does that apply what was being paid what
do you mean you mean what where is that
where did the money go yeah like what
was being funded with that money
Oh tax reductions in other words people
are paying less in taxes and they are
keeping it and they're
disproportionately rich people in
corporations I mean they can do whatever
they want with the money and that's
where part of the speculation as to the
economic benefit is yeah I mean that
money was going into were like the IRS
or something or yeah it was it was going
it was government revenue previously
when it was coming any was government
revenue and it became part of the budget
which we run as a deficit of course all
right and so then okay that's a other
wondering like if they were previously
had that money to fund programs whether
Republican or Democrat programs you
can't say now it's like good tax revenue
goes in and it funds government so you
can't say now the money that is going
back to rich people from the tax cuts
was only funding this program or that
program I mean now we've got a new
budget that's been submitted by the
White House and we have to see what
eventually becomes the official budget
but it's it's not quite so simple but
it's money that used to come to the
government that now is going to you know
disproportionately rich people all right
yep all right thanks very much what I
was able to clear that up for you